deux cents bénévoles ont répondu
présents pour mettre leurs talents de
couturiers aux couturières au service
des enfants plaisir aux as
il y a deux semaines la ville a lancé un
appel pour un défi solidaire équiper les
3500 élèves de masque en tissu
réutilisables à l'origine du projet en
fait on ne savait pas si les écoles à la
reprise des écoles salles et masquer la
était obligatoire ou pas pour les
enfants
donc on a lancé ce projet en se disant
est ce qu'on avait des personnes qui
pouvaient nous aider à créer ces masques
enfants puisque dans le commerce était
très compliquée voire impossible de les
avoir donc nos bénévoles nous ont dit
oui pas de problème par contre on n'a
pas de matières premières typiquement
l'élastique était introuvable
un fournisseur a été trouvé pour les
élastiques pour le tissu nécessaires à
la confection des masques et la ville a
fait appel à une entreprise plaisir oise
500 kits ont ainsi pu être distribués
aux bénévoles
je fais 30 masques ce que tu es déjà pas
mal gens intéressants comme certaine que
j'ai en effet en plus avec mes
fournitures à moi pour mes voisins tout
mamies du quartier et un sit in pour le
non ce n'était pas pas compliqué avec le
point exact de la chine au début était
pas très voulait faire grève
donc j'ai négocié à l'école primaire les
masques de protection ne seront pas
obligatoires pour les enfants mais ils
pourront tout de même l'utiliser dans
leur quotidien on a eu tellement de
bonne volonté et ses déchets pense que
les parents sont ravis d'avoir un masque
pour leurs enfants pour aller faire pour
aller prendre les transports en commun
pour aller faire les courses
un masque sera remis à chaque élève dès
qu'il fera sa rentrée